i don't even like using the word urn to
be quite honest it just sounds a bit
morbid this is a piece of my grandmother
that i keep with me all the time
over the past decade or so ash's
creations have started to appear
[Music]
i look at it and i just remember all the
good times we had
[Music]
in classical greece and rome you had
both burial and cremation practices
taking place because in other parts of
the world
traditional aspects in in buddhism again
cremation because the jews never
cremation burial normative islam burial
but of course long before this india
was a cremation culture and once
christianity became established in the
uk cremation was basically forbidden and
that continued really until the mid 19th
century when with industrialization and
the rise of big towns big cities
churchyards got full fast the miasmas
the gases that were rising from
putrefied bodies were considered to be
very unhealthy the cremation society was
founded in 1874 by sir henry thompson
who was a celebrated surgeon and he was
joined by a number of free thinkers who
were drawn from the realms of medicine
science and the arts
[Music]
price was really a very flamboyant
character a welsh nationalist and
self-appointed art druid of wales
[Music]
price was arrested
and sent to trial at cardiff sizes where
judge stephen ruled that cremation was
not illegal providing it didn't cause
any public nuisance so in 1902
the cremation act was passed
[Music]
so by the time we get into the
1940s and 50s something really
interesting was happening you were
having women dying who no longer had a
husband's grave that they had to go into
so the issue of choice
that cremation was now as it were on the
cards and a possibility and it's about
the middle of the 1960s that britain
flips from being
burial majority to cremation majority
it's really extraordinary that the
percentage of deaths that resulted in
cremation in 1939 stood 3.5 percent and
now of course the cremation rate in the
uk stands at nearly 80 percent
from something like the mid-1970s
the british started doing something
which many people on the continent to
this day find weird they started taking
cremated remains away from the
crematorium and doing their own thing
with them just seems weird to call it an
urn to me
i like to think of it as a piece of art
we just happen to have my mum and dad
inside it this is a piece of my
grandmother and my memorial jewelry that
i keep with me all the time all ash's
creations
are about keeping our loved ones close
any memorial is for the people left
behind it's never
for
the person it's for
us to carry on
with that memorial it's allowed the dead
to become part of the furniture of our
life it's made the dad more mobile my
ash's creation is a tattoo and it
includes the ashes of my late partner
who passed away two and a half years ago
a small number of people choose to have
ashes mixed into tattoo ink he was my
friend and i also got a tattoo
and their bodies are literally mingled
together
[Music]
as chair of the cremation society i will
naturally choose to be cremated i think
my daughter will
have me incorporated into a vinyl record
because i love music maybe something by
the beastie boys
i do not belong
to the tattoo generation i don't think
there's enough room in there to fit me
in with them
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video